all right there Kurdish you need a glass
of water
spoink t spear or the iron door pure din
fears and i smart air hahahaha
faceplant right in the landmine super
speed yet that is like way too many jets
or not enough thing could've died hey
they can't do anything before throttle
okay let's actually try angry mob escape
oh god what have I done
I killed in Co you'll pay for what you
have done seeds these are watermelons
and I didn't mean to pshh
I didn't mean to kill you there's no way
I can't I can't get through this patch
quick it off I keep getting so bad y'all
right there mom
you all right you need something you
need a glass of water this is not even
remotely possible not possible
well what's going on what's happening
the group is all God torso on the run oh
did I make it
oh no not another come on I'll do sick
tricks don't you mess up my body but I
got your ass no it's my dick this is
kind of weird this isn't normal not
normal I'm gonna hold it hot chica Wow
oh not again I'm gonna slap you in the
tits oh oh I got you back how do you
like me now [ __ ] Oh who's cow you stab
me in the back you do she'll the thief
oh wait no I didn't you didn't oh maybe
you should give me some kind of a
warning what I'm supposed to do this is
the thief I think that was just some guy
in his home but you you son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna getcha I'm gonna stab you in
your groin and then stab you up through
your anus
all right you kiddies it's been a long
night in the Laverne presents it's time
to go back to our cave to rest for
another year at hiber what something
just happen the trust is back stop
complaining let's cloth left I've been
alone and sad and cold and angry and
bitter and drunk no it does before now
I'm worried my little kitties go oh well
no big deal Wow meme world one I get
okay that's that face that's it Oh
[Laughter]
actually kill me all right so you then
megusta go you gusta too hard
fly like Superman uh pansy little
Superman doesn't explode at the end and
round and big I have no other
compliments for you Oh fine first Wow as
you go friend
oh no Janna Santa's
telepods was near me I think I saw the
war now what am I here okay Santa but
send a bag Oh God
yet pack your Wow this level looks
really nice I missed those coin how I
died alrighty then just need to be a bit
more careful not touch the poisons room
thanks for defending me with your ass
Mario get back madness press spacebar to
be oh wow can I lean forward a bit I
would be able to go faster if I could
just lean forward
oh no I'm not but I think my body is
gonna be carrying along with me
everybody hold on a few seconds I just
got to keep along the letters they're
guiding me to my destination although
last time they kind of led me astray I
cut the engine right up the end here cut
it right here right you kitties what's
that well I don't care if you didn't get
what you wanted for Christmas you got a
deal with it Santa's going away Santa's
gonna go back oh you want some too hot
cookies well you all got lumps of coal
shells up your ass and you're gonna like
it so that's just what you're gonna have
to deal with oh good good I gotta baking
it I'm baking it up come on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're good enough to beat me oh I got
that in your dingdong Oh what I was not
done yet I did not kill Santa oh my Oh
trust my fall we and it aw god damn it
you come back here you [ __ ] I need you
how could this happen in me I made
members days got no it and life goes on
as I'm feeding Louie we all do this
every to me of a Bella's day around uh
why you put me back you [ __ ] horn horn
pause there Blair found war francais Oh
La Belle Isle une baguette le pas de for
tower
Alistair in there
b.o.b a snake what are you kidding me
this is awesome this is like the coolest
thing I've ever seen
I'm not been a dragon before but look at
this look is goofy a snake over here
like this crawl Ian wait oh that's so
cool kinda it's kind of creepy too but
still cool oh look it is on doofy Mouse
oh-ho-ho baby there yeah you better run
snakes gonna get you oh don't you try to
stop me do I just notice he has like two
buck teeth up front
yo was just very cool good job
[Applause]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye